[Music]
I've written prepared to leave the EU a
small party thrown in central London by
a handful of breakfasts most ardent
supporters we can do now is look to the
future and hopefully this country will
prosper now we have got a chain around
much of the country is more muted though
yes this is a moment of huge national
significance but little actually changes
until the transition period finishes at
the end of the year and it's not yet
clear where the country is heading this
is the man currently in the UK's driving
seat before he got the job many thought
it wasn't a natural fit but in December
Boris Johnson won a crushing landslide
election victory on the promise that
he'd finally get brexit done Britain
seemed to have voted to put three years
of arguing in political paralysis behind
them but plenty see the argument that
something Titanic has been achieved is
so much hot air like in Northern Ireland
for example which is more exposed to
brexit Sun certainties than anywhere
else in the UK it completely recasts
reshapes the political and economic
conversation across the island between
the island of Ireland and Britain and
right across the continent so this isn't
an endpoint this is very much a
beginning certainly the heavy lifting
sorting out the UK's trade relationship
with Europe everything from fishing to
financial services is still to come all
the political signs in the UK and that
the UK want to see diverge from the from
the EU not to be part of this sort of
sphere of influence of the European
Union but all the sort of dynamics of
the negotiations point to a quick tail
and a quick deal means trying to come up
with alignment in key areas that are
going to be in the EU interest in Europe
the message is clear or proof the more
the UK will diverge from EU standards
the less access to the single market
they will have the EU will be looking to
its own priorities and trying to solve
its own challenges the UK is already
receding
importance we want to have the best
possible relationship with the United
Kingdom but it will never be as good as
membership the EU wants to show there's
little to be gained from walking out the
door borage halon's al jazeera london